all right the coolest movie of 2014
finally in 2021
[Music]
so black widow is pretty much what i
said in the intro of this video it's the
black widow standalone movie black widow
the character from the mcu
we see events of her backstory that have
been referenced in the mcu before we see
a little more of that but basically in
this movie there's a big russian baddie
so she reunites with her
russian family and taskmasters in it
kind of and we'll say the setup in this
movie was actually
really good everything from the
beginning to the beginning credits the
beginning credits were actually really
good it does a good job at making you
latch on to this family of spies and
you're like okay i mean we already liked
black widow
you don't really need too much setup for
that but after the setup the movie
and has enjoyment in it the things that
i enjoyed in this movie are the things
that i
generally enjoy in the mcu movies it's
reliable in that way it has all the
action scenes and the cgi
action scenes and the set pieces that
are also cgi
all the explosions all the excitement
that you would come to expect
from a big blockbuster movie coming from
the biggest studio on earth of course
you're gonna get all that in here
but it does kind of run into that fast
nine scenario like my review of fast and
the furious 9 where i was saying
the action sequences are so over the top
they don't feel dangerous it doesn't
always do that in here there are a
couple moments where i was like yeah
that was that was pretty intense but
when black widow is doing this [ __ ]
and you know she doesn't die in this
movie because this movie takes place
right after captain america
civil war and we know how she goes out
and this isn't it
it's just not that exciting it's cool
looking but that is different the movie
also does the thing that
frustrates me about mcu movies in
general
is the fact that they always deflect
with jokes jokes are great
humor is fine it can actually add to the
experience of enjoyment but when there's
clearly a scene that could have
benefited for letting the drama marinade
and go to the next step but they don't
they just crack a joke it's just
frustrating like the scene where
florence
character is talking about her
involuntary hysterectomy and it's just
executed in a very jokey jokey haha mcu
kind of way i was like yeah that's a
weird way of
telling your father figure that you had
an involuntary hysterectomy pretty heavy
topic could have been a really good
dramatic moment a moment that could have
elevated the movie to the next level
but no then there's another scene with
florence pugh's character i was side
note i really like florence p
in this movie i think she does
everything she can with the script she
has
disclaimer i think florence p was
generally great and she is in this movie
too but she has this moment where she
really is frustrated and then david
harbor's character starts singing
american pie because she likes the song
and she googles and sings american pie
and
after that they could have had another
moment
like okay let's really form this bond
but no they get ambushed okay
well now david harbor can have a bad ass
scene to protect her and really show how
much he cares but no we're the mcu we're
gonna take this moment to just knock out
david harbor's character in a funny way
and that's that you know in the script
writing process there are like
many eyes that go on the script which is
great you know a second pair of eyes it
can catch something that the first pair
of eyes doesn't catch you know it's the
collaborative effort
it's good to have that but i think the
mcu has a dedicated room a room titled
when it gets too heavy
we deflect with the jokes it's a working
title but i think these people in this
room
look over the script like oh that's
getting too heavy deflect with a joke
here
oh yeah that's gonna elevate the movie
way too much deflect with a joke here
i think that's how it goes down and
bring it up because it's happened
so often in the mcu and it happens in
here too but hey jokes
the play is safe reliably entertaining
and they are reliably entertaining i
mean david harbour like
florence pu does the best with what he
has
david harbor when you just want someone
to be the brute
you know like the funny brute guy he
crushes it he's so good in this movie in
that role but i'm also frustrated that
he doesn't have
those moments that could have gone the
extra step because
he's a good actor he could have done
that even his fight with task mastery
like oh
david herbert versus taskmaster let's do
it this is gonna be epic but it keeps
cutting away
before you can really enjoy it doesn't
give you that opportunity to sit there
and just enjoy the fight and i've heard
from some people that task master was
kind of disappointing in this movie
for me taskmaster wasn't kinda
disappointing taskmaster was the most
disappointing mcu villain i've seen in
the mcu
yet you get so much more development for
taskmaster
in the ps4 game let me say that again
the menial
side tasks you do for taskmaster in the
spider-man game for ps4
and the ps5 remaster gives you so much
more insight into taskmaster
than this movie ever gives you it's just
weird to me it's strange to say
taskmaster in this movie is just some
[ __ ] drone assassin
also never says a word in the entire
movie taskmaster is essentially snake
eyes which is funny because
now snake guys talks it's like
taskmaster now is how snake eyes was
before and snake eyes now
is how taskmaster was before it's like
i'm in an alternate universe or
something regardless this was my
mandarin moment
you know when people saw iron man 3 and
their big mandarin fans and they were
like
that was not mandarin like that's how i
felt about taskmaster granted we're
getting a mulligan of mandarin and
legend of the 10 ring so who knows maybe
seven or eight years from now
we can get actual taskmaster in the mcu
until then
we have this throwaway villain but it
does feel like a frankenstein a
frankenstitch of other
mcu movie concepts that we've already
seen that were just thrown into this
movie because they were like fine
fans want their black widow movie here i
mean you got the batty character that
comes on scene to cause some problems
terminator style after some action goes
down they go to this location in the
middle of nowhere to lick their wounds
and plan their next move
have a big final fight scene in a big
sky fortress there's even some x-men 2
thrown in here for good measure but it's
frustrating because none of it feels
inspired it just feels like they slapped
all these things together because they'd
seen and done them before and they're
like here that'll shut them up yeah how
can we make this fast easy and in a
hurry
so we can make up for some of that clout
we lost yeah just pull from those other
mcu movies that we already did and
stitched them together into this movie
yeah black widow why not it just feels
lazy i mean the movie is
fine i wouldn't say 30 bucks on disney
plus
fine maybe it'll be a better time if
you're drunk yeah
now it's a party but again love florence
p love david harbour
but captain america winter soldier is a
better black widow movie
than the actual black widow movie
alright so black widow have you seen it
are you gonna see it how are mcu movies
hitting you now as long as you're
enjoying life that's the important thing
but whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you